just of uh um the knockout stage a bit
of the tournament it's been so it's been
so up and down i mean it might not be
the best game recording computer but for
drama it's been great because they both
missed wins they've both been attacking
they've both turned down draws it's got
everything uh that you'd want in a game
this is going to look good on the
fighting chess index i was about to say
the same card their fighting index
scores are going to go through the roof
after this game and uh yeah i mean fair
play to both players now the game will i
think finally reach its conclusion we
saw a couple of checks from white but no
progress to be made black's pawn just
simply too strong but he has to keep
checking otherwise black will win and uh
here we go we're about to see
the second draw of the final
dramatic draw it's been i bet you they
both shake their head right you know
when when they when they had the draw
they i bet you they both like oh no
that's it yeah
yeah yeah yeah
we just want to see if we will will
magnus shake his head give us a head
shake magnus
the uh is definitely shaking is